[Music]
now before you judge this is exactly
what it looks like the Haram genre is
one of the most respected genres you can
possibly find in anime said absolutely
no one this is a genre people often put
at the bottom of the barrel of
entertainment along with stuff like the
eiz genre which hold up okay there we go
okay I absolutely agree with but
recently it feels like the genre is
going through a bit of an evolution no
longer can you get away with some boring
vanilla premise anymore there needs to
be some unique gimmick like what if all
the love interests were quintuplets or
what if the winner was actually the
loser or what if we have a show like
girlfriend girlfriend where a series
said instead of leading up to one single
final winner what if we just indulge in
the harm cuz boys why set off one girl
when you can have
[Music]
multiple but what if we could have more
what if two three or even four
girlfriends wasn't
enough well right now we have a show so
insane so so unhinge we are now limit
testing polygamy a series about one man
who found the infinite Riz glitch became
the Apex of all boyfriends and in the
process may have pushed this genre to
new heights so if you looked at a series
like girlfriend girlfriend and thought
to yourself can we get much higher I
present to you the 100 girlfriends who
really really really really really love
[Music]
you but if 100 girls still isn't enough
for you to choose from then don't worry
because we have today's sponsor Arc
recode now fair warning that this is
going to be for distinguished gentlemen
and ladies above the age of 18 only as
it's a new apocalyptic strategic mobile
adult RPG listed by aabs Arc recode
allows you to lead a squad of sexy
Charming girls on an Epic Quest in the
year 2122 an unknown entity from the far
corner of the universe sent an apostle
to Earth to wipe out Humanity survivors
discover a new energy source called
astrogenic civilization in the safe
havens known as arcs however just as the
world seem to have settled down once
again the people discovered another
Apostle disguised as a woman lurking on
Earth to prevent the disaster happening
again it's up to you to lead a team of
beautiful Elites to combat the threat to
humanity this is a game that gives you
multiple options in more than one way
you can pick your own strategic approach
thanks to hundreds of different skill
combinations and take your pick of
hundreds of unique girls with their own
unique personalities save the world and
make the perfect Haram just in time for
the holidays ho ho ho Arc recode is
available on both IOS and Android
devices but make sure you download the
game directly from Air laab site you can
try out Arc Reco today by clicking that
link in the description and entering
promo code gigar to receive exclusive
prises thanks again to Arc recode for
sponsoring today's video back to 100
girlfriends Reno has an incurable
disease since birth he's been infected
with an illness known as negative RZ I'm
sure many of us know of at least one
poor soul who's been infected with such
an illness right graduating from school
he decides to try his luck One Last Time
by confessing to the girl he likes and
asking her out and
uh she says no this marks a new record
for him as he's now been rejected a 100
times ever since his first confession
when when he was just 8 months old
that's right my boy's been trying to
chat up girls before he achieved objects
permanence his friends give him a
Parting Gift a Knighthood dubbing him
sir bitchless Baron or forever Singleton
damn man they have no chill so feeling
like all hope is lost he turns to the
one and only thing that can possibly
flip his life around and score him a
girlfriend divine intervention and
somehow it worked at a shrine he's
praying out he meets God who informs
rento that he made a little oopsie he's
accidentally given him 100 different
soulmates who he's going to be meeting
soon Jack what I hear you say think of
all the girls think of all the choices
oh by the way any girl that rro doesn't
choose will die bummer who should he
pick who should he reject knowing the
consequences with a matter of life or
death the prospect of having blood on
his hands he stands up faces the music
and makes the decision only a true
protagonist can make if the girls I
don't choose dies there is only one
choice to be made I will date all of
them
the show is [__] stupid the Haram
genre has never exactly been The
Benchmark of highbrow entertainment so
for those who don't normally indulge in
it you may not understand what the
appeal is is it for the
[Music]
romance no Haram anime are Sports Anime
in Disguise let me say that again Haram
anime are Sports Anime in disguise
find me another genre where you see
weebs forming different teams based on
picking a side they really want to win
and completely investing themselves into
cheering for that side's Victory staying
dedicated throughout the entire run of
the series while [__] on any
supporters on the opposing sides [__]
this is more of a sport than actual
Sports Anime you have the glory
supporters now these are the [__]
that pick one of the first girls that
are introduced that are almost always
guaranteed to be the winner they know
the rules first girl wins is the bookie
favorite and they're happy to play the
odds then you have the fans of the local
teams these guys think they're above
supporting the big Brand's Mainline
girls so they'll cheer for their second
tier side character girls that will
introduce in the mid game they want to
feel better by picking the girl that no
one else is picking and maybe just maybe
this time the girl actually has a chance
of winning like any sport you follow
your team through to the end no matter
how many years it takes no matter how
many hundreds of chapters until
eventually a single girl gets picked if
it's your girl you celebrating Euphoria
you had the best taste your girl got the
ending she deserved and like any true
sports fan watching your girl win is as
sweet as laughing at anyone now on
suicide watch for backing the losing
horse but if your girl lost there's only
one thing you can do come together with
your fellow degenerates and cry about it
together you'll tell yourselves it's all
right she deserved better than that
bland protagonist anyway right and that
moment will become a scar you carry that
will be forever etched in the hearts of
fans like any sporting event Falcons
blew a 283 lead PSG blew a 61 lead r
blew nutso then gave him to a vegetable
this is the foundation of a Haram Series
so how can a series in the genre work
where every girl is the winner every
girl gets picked there is no losing team
cuz everyone immediately wins why you
make fun of all that [__] let's be real
when you're watching a series about some
plain boring ass guy with arage looks
suddenly having a bunch of hot girls all
foring and fighting over him you aren't
exactly coming into this for some
realism you can relate to in your own
life right oh God he's flatlining we
need more with Haram anime your
suspension of disbelief has been pushed
beyond the stretch's Fe already so to
parody it 100 girlfriend goes let's just
completely obliterate that everything
everything has been exaggerated to the
point of insanity plot design characters
we don't have five girls or 10 girls we
have 100 girls Karan isn't just a cinder
she's a turbo Cinder shiza isn't just
shy she's turbo shy hakari isn't just
horny she Ms liser and genin impact the
series takes all the most ridiculous
tropes in cliches we see in the genre
DARS a knob up to 100 [__] around and
finds out and you know what it actually
works there's a SE early on where the
characters have got into a bit of a
conundrum Reno has successfully
convinced the first two girlfriends to
date him simultaneously mission
accomplished but there's a problem this
is a romance anime and what's the most
important endgame achievement for any
romance anime that's right sharing the
first kiss but how can you share a first
kiss when you have two girls you love
equally to receive that kiss sounds like
we got ourselves a little bit of a
pickley Lads so the girls have a full 1
V1 Fox only Final Destination girlfriend
off trying to outgirl each other only
the superior girlfriend will be the
lucky recipient of that first kiss but
no there is no unfairness no infighting
allowed in the rento family so the
gigachad himself has the perfect
solution coin toss rock paper scissors
nah he devises a system where they split
up and stand up at randomized points
based on a dice roll they are all
blindfolded having music blaring in
their ears at full blast he rolls a dice
Waits a random number of seconds based
on that dice roll so neither girl knows
if he's waited a long or short time then
rolls again he goes left if it's odd
right if it's even kisses the girl then
moves on to kiss the other girl once
he's finished he returns to the starting
position and Bobs your uncle the first
kiss with each girl has been
accomplished and neither party knows who
the first kiss was with this is the
first kiss
equalizer this is one of the S things
you ever see in the show does this mean
it's a show that's above showing fan
service because it's meant to be
parodying
[Music]
[Laughter]
Haram no it knows how to openly poke fun
of the genre without being overly
reliant on cheap shots because the
biggest compliment I can give it is that
Beyond being just a parody the casts
have genuine chemistry with each other
Always Sunny Parks and Recreation peep
show a lot of my favorite sitcoms have a
core cast that already works so well
with each other so the secret is just
putting them in different situations to
see how they'd act and 100 girlfriends
is like putting an all you can e Buffet
of every insane character tribe you see
in anime in the most unhinged situations
you can think of and seeing what kind of
Insanity would ensue the girls play off
each other as much as they do rento they
fight with each other banter with each
other sincerely care for one another
every every girl has a different Dynamic
with every other girl and partway
through the series The Haram starts
acting more like some dysfunctional
family than anything else when I started
this series I thought it was going to be
some low XD silly meme show with a funny
gimmick that I will get bored of after a
few episodes but after I caught up to
the anime and realized that wasn't
enough I started blasting through the
manga and it was around girlfriend 12
that it slowly started to dawn on me
that holy [__] this isn't just a gimmick
these mad Lads are actually committing
to the idea you think with such a
batshit crazy concept it'd be easy to
just rush through it introduce a bunch
of girls and relegate most of them to
background NPCs to let a select fuse
shine but as you continue reading you
see the author going the extra mile for
every single one of them every girl gets
the time to shine not a single one of
them is some half-baked stereotype even
if they start off with some Trope you've
seen before the series takes his time to
get you to care about each and every one
of them as a person this is one of those
shows that tells you not to take it too
seriously then triples the [__] down on
these serious moments you weren't
expecting to make it hit even harder and
for any other Haron manga this would
simply collapse under the weight of its
own ambition but 100 girlfriends has the
glue that binds everything together
Michael Jordan lonel Messi Muhammad Ali
Tiger Woods what do they have in common
with AIO Reno that's right they're the
goats of their respective positions I me
with multiple woman my man saw Japan's
population crisis and said fine I'll do
it myself here is someone in line to
Father more children than genas Khan and
you know genas Khan himself once said
and I quote the greatest joy for a man
is to defeat his enemies to drive them
before him to take all they possess to
see those they love in tears to ride
their hes and hold their wives and
daughters in his arms so clearly Gang
has played League of Legends but rro
isn't a toxic gamer like that he
captures the hearts of women by being
the best damn boyfriend is actually
possible to be if there was a complete
antithesis to kazia Reno would be it he
doesn't just show love to his
girlfriends he downright worships his
girlfriends every single one of them
equally and you know what he [__]
deserves it here is a man who has only
known rejection in his life the Giga
Chad confessed 100 times failed 100
times and didn't let that phase him
where every other Haron protagonist
takes 200 chapters to come to terms with
their feelings Reno only knows the pain
of
unrequired from crippling shyness she
was a background character and just by
getting a bit of attention she would
disappear all she could muster up was
the strength to confess behind a wall
and that was okay that was all she
needed to be satisfied before she would
fade away again and she did she would
never be seen again it was said as the
chapter comes to to an end only for Reno
to rip the manga pages to shred Force
the chapter to keep going goes literally
super humid looking for her and didn't
stop until he could say I love you [__]
this is a man who would shatter the
fourth wall literally bend the laws of
reality to make every single one of his
girlfriend's happy he is the Apex
boyfriend every boyfriend aspires to be
and under his watch there is no best
girl War every girl is equally loved all
girls are best girl there is no contest
if the readers want to vote on their
favorite he will literally rig the votes
so every single one of the girls get the
same amount in the Haram series
containing the Haram of harams
theoretically the most ferocious
Battlefield you'd be able to find in
anime he's achieved the waifu world
peace now if that's not real power I
don't know what is 100 girlfriends is
truly an enigma a series with an insane
premise that actually fully commits to
it and delivers where most of the series
in a genre is parodying fails currently
we're about 150 chapters in and about 26
girlfriends have been introduced at the
time of recording yes we are only just
over a quarter of the way through and
the author has said they are fully
dedicated to getting that full 100 so no
matter how many more hundreds of
chapters or years I have to wait you bet
your ass I will be sticking with this
whatever the end game of this Haram
looks like I got my glasses how much are
these
$9.99 you think I can get some [__]
with
[Music]
these hey guys hope you enjoyed that
video thank you for very much this month
too author Curtis X basil dysfunctional
degenerate flabber husbando Hub Mike 808
misaka 12315 pain patchet Pony Stark
shouting zombie water gist VT and
everyone else my patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible after this video I
realized I think I may have an addiction
to manga with the word girlfriend in it
and I have no idea why domestic
girlfriend rent a girlfriend 100
girlfriends I'm sure there's another
girlfriend I'm missing h yeah I have a
problem Oh God they've discovered the
secret to make me read the Manga anyway
though guys hope you are ready for this
Christmas holiday this is going to be
the last video this year before my best
of anime of 2023 coming out in January
next year I'm going to be enjoying my
Christmas holiday as well so I hope you
do as well anyway though that's been it
from me I've been gig and I'll see you
all next time